crazy rich Asians is directed by Jon M
Chu and stars Constance Wu as Rachel a
native New Yorker whose traveling to
Singapore to meet her boyfriend's family
and there she learns that they are
insanely rich so she has to navigate
this family path while also trying to be
there for her boyfriend and hopefully
having a normal relationship because all
of this is very new to her now obviously
it's it's pretty hard to review this
movie without acknowledging the
significance of its cast this is one of
Hollywood's first exclusively all Asian
casts in a long time and this is pretty
monumental and this is something that's
pretty awesome and Hollywood's
definitely listening right now they're
kind of like hey what do you guys like
and the way to communicate to Hollywood
is through your chequebook of course
because Hollywood is definitely going to
be paying attention to the box-office
receipts of this film this weekend
whether or not they want to make more
films with casts like this which is kind
of silly to me that this cast has to
prove itself by making a lot of money
that we can't just get films like this
unless they prove themselves first I
understand that filmmaking is an
investment and they want to make a
return I get all that I know how hard it
is to make a movie but all I'm saying is
it Hollywood's paying attention so so
pay for a ticket to see this movie and
go see it because this film isn't
amazing it's not a perfect movie it has
faults it's definitely entertaining and
as a romantic comedy I did enjoy myself
but the success financially of this
movie and similar to Black Panther
earlier this year will lead to bigger
and better things now that I've said all
that I can tell you that if this film
wasn't good and if I wasn't entertained
and if I didn't think this was a fun and
enjoyable romantic comedy I would tell
you and they did a good job this is
actually a really entertaining movie and
I'm happy to say that I had a fun time
watching the film and I laughed quite
often one of the biggest reasons is
because of the culture on display the
food's the architecture the locales and
this incredibly talented cast Aquafina
is hilarious in this movie I thought she
was kind of alright in ocean's 8 she was
a little grating in that film but he or
she hits that
perfect level her humor is sprinkled
throughout the film at various moments
and she really adds a nice amount of
levity to the film Constance whoo I
think it's terrific Michelle Yeoh who at
this point is a legend is also really
good as the boyfriends mother she's
incredibly intimidating she's the type
of person you need to impress almost
instantly and you can probably tell
within a few seconds if she hates you or
not and she's a very impressive
character but she's equally great in the
film and it was really the conflict
between her character and Rachel that I
found most interesting because while
this film absolutely follows a very
similar romantic comedy formula that I
have seen in countless films over the
years what I liked about it was that
conflict and how she constantly had to
try to impress her or or dodge her or
kind of maneuver through some of her
more difficult questions to show that
she was worthy of being in this family
which eventually becomes a major issue
for these characters and once that
conflict really set a flame the movie
got a lot more interesting up until then
it was just kind of enjoyable and it had
some boring moments to be honest this
film could definitely be better but it's
the charisma of the cast the beautiful
locations the amazing set design of
production design and costume design
because they're there for a wedding and
this is one of the most beautiful
weddings I've ever seen portrayed in a
film I actually thought it was really
gorgeous and obviously the monumental
achievement of having a movie like this
be released in America today and it will
more than likely do really well this
weekend and hopefully Hollywood listens
and we get better films with casts like
this as a result because well this is a
perfectly entertaining romantic comedy I
would love to see a much better film
with a cast like this the film really
does pick up in its second half once
everyone gets to Singapore and that
conflict between these characters starts
that first half is a bit meandering and
it does feel like every other romantic
comedy you've seen a million times but
by the end I did find myself wrapped up
in these characters and I thought the
entire cast did an amazing job
I'm gonna have crazy rich Asians Abbi I
think most audience members are going to
enjoy this film and lead
perfectly happy I think the film totally
did its job but it's a little more
important than that for some like when I
went to the theater there were tons of
asian-americans there and I could just
tell that they were happy like they felt
included and and that's something that
this film is going to do that I think as
a stepping stone to greater things this
film is important so if you can go see
it this weekend and throw some money
their way because it actually is a
pretty enjoyable romantic comedy it's a
great date movie for sure and that's
probably the best way you can see this
film if it's if it's a date so guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and look forward to more reviews very
soon and if you like this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]